good morning Paul how are you good
morning Dan I saved you a seat for the
Texas A&M Northwestern State game I know
you would like to bring the whole crew
over I love that yeah you know that when
those two just schools get together you
throw out the records I mean when you
break a few windows in the process where
is Northwestern State it is in nationís
Louisiana and please don't ask me to
spell it and I don't even think I
pronounced it correctly but I want to
lived in Louisiana so I visited it once
it's just it's really pretty city pretty
good football tradition not as much as
Louisiana Tech with Terry Bradshaw of
course if you were going to have
somebody go to the single most intense
fan base game surrounding environment
what would it be I know it's a cliche to
say but but I really like LSU because
I've lived in the state I've been to so
many classic games there and I think a
night game in Baton Rouge with Alabama
coming to town especially Nick Saban and
if it starts after dark listen the
culture there loves to watch football
and they love the watch football after
having been intoxicating themselves
since whenever they wake up which is
usually not early on Saturday morning
has LSU forgiven Nick Saban well they
have national championship after saving
left with Les Miles and his acolytes
said for a long time that Saban had
nothing to do with it but he had
everything to do with it
customer national championship team and
after les was summarily dismissed
two years ago Nick I think is actually
claiming credit for that l that LSU
national championship under under Miles
it gives him 47 all right let's dive
into the topic here what happened at the
University of Maryland yesterday what
did it mean to you and where are we
going with this story
I saw college president speak from the
heart and that may be the first time in
in my lifetime dan that I've seen that
and you can quibble and argue that
president LOH was late to the party but
regardless of that he took
responsibility
he took legal and moral responsibility
in today's litigious society you don't
hear that very often so I appreciated
that I thought he said a very good tone
he didn't say a lot of things and what I
don't think he said was we are going to
fire our football coach at the first
available moment and certainly there is
some sort of due process going on right
now with DJ Durkins but I do not believe
he can survive and I don't believe he
should survive he brought these people
in he's on record in talking about the
strength and conditioning coaches saying
we needed to change our culture and he
is the man to do that he's a very
intense individual as the latter
football coaches are but but in if you
if you are to believe the ESPN article
the other day about the culture of the
program which is separate from the death
it is a bad place and it needs to be
corrected yeah I I heard some
culpability there with the president it
just feels like like why did it take
this long for everything and I'm all for
due process you know do your due
diligence here it just felt like
Maryland was trying to say to that you
know that ESPN report hey you know don't
believe that you know the anonymous
source is here and you know meanwhile
ESPN did a great job in in vetting this
and bringing it to light so why did it
take so long to have a press conference
like though because I think for the most
part this death was overlooked dan it
only came up because the athletic
director was being vetted in the
aftermath damon.evans
and he was he was asked about it and his
answer is apparently satisfied the
committee choosing the new athletic
director there
and I'm really curious while Urban Meyer
and I know that's another subject was
questioned at Big Ten media days about
the Zack Smith situation I don't
remember hearing anyone questioned
gherkin about this situation so you're I
think we all moved on as we often do and
it takes a an explosive report and I
thought some of the commentary on the
report were ridiculous namely Will
Muschamp
if you saw his comments but Dirk can
work for him an urban at Florida and he
unloaded on it saying you can't believe
in on the sources and I'm not trying to
be comical here but I would remind coach
much and to maybe go back in history and
read all the president's men to see if
anonymous sources can change the the the
future of our country anonymous source
has helped overthrow a president and
they and they've done a lot of good
things I'm not defending apparently the
journalism because I've been in that
business for a long time because we get
a lot of things wrong but for the most
part anonymous sources it takes somebody
very brave to speak up about a culture
especially when they are inside that
culture
yeah I'm right there with you I called
out Will Muschamp on this I thought he
was blind to this you can have loyalty
but you also have to have perspective
and also when it comes to how this is
going to affect other college programs
you know when Korey stringer died
Minnesota Vikings offensive lineman it
felt like okay that sent shockwaves
through the NFL everybody is going to
have certain protocol their medical
staff defibrillator
whatever you need we're gonna have that
with all these camps now college is
different there's so many of these
programs how do you think what happened
with Jordan McNair and this coaching
staff strength and conditioning coach
does it have any aftershocks with other
programs I think it has too because in
every program in America they had a
conversation two weeks ago after after
the Urban Meyer situation broke and I
have a feeling they're doing it again
and this is this is fairly complicated
because when you try to change a culture
at a program that's usually while you
bring a new coaching staff in the first
place you go is a strength and
conditioning coach not to bring Saban
and do it again but when he he brought
Scott Cochran to Alabama that was what
he is often pointed to as the biggest
change in the program Cochran has been
tried to Kirby Smart tried to woo him
away for for seven figures a couple
years ago and Sabin kept him because
that is critical that that's where it
all begins and I'm not talking from
experience I'm talking from experience
in talking to people who have been there
before and and in this case you have an
in coach Dirk and a very intense
individual I was reading a story today
and that he was on hardball staff at
Stanford and later at Michigan and they
would play one-on-one basketball games
and Harbaugh said later that they played
a 90 minute one-on-one game no fouls
were called and there was blood on the
court and I bring that up because that's
that's what we're talking about we're
not talking about music professors here
and I don't mean to belittle them but
they are there maybe a little calmer
type of people they may be equally
intense but they're not they're not
usually playing one-on-one basketball
games it was blood and guts football
coaches are competitive as many people
in every industry are and I think it's
hard to be able to to legislate how far
you can go but in in this particular
case and the president said it better
than I can simple basic mistakes were
made that you could probably learn at a
sixth grade first grade first aid class
I mean that that I mean it's inexcusable
to overlook things like like we're
overlooked on this day we're talking to
Paul Finebaum voice of the SEC ESPN
radio host is Urban Meyer in the clear
at Ohio State I think he's pretty close
and again we're all all speculating III
think most of us who have given opinions
on this have pretty much hit every every
corner of the square it looked like he
was done early it doesn't look like he
is now and I say that just based on
having watch college football Dan and
understanding the cynical nature of it
and I'm trying to trying to get a good
measure of that fan base who just
doesn't seem to have any desire to try
to get to the truth here or or to
believe the other side and that's that's
the most confusing part of this and I
would suspect the the sixth person can
he is hearing the same things that we
have all heard and it really has come
down unfortunately to a he-said she-said
urban is he's avoided land mines for
three decades now I mean it just feels
like he knows what to do is build for it
and I think worst-case scenarios he
probably gets suspended a couple of
games but I don't know if it's gonna
amount to anything more than that your
thoughts you know in listen he is he is
a great football coach there's no one
will deny that you know what would know
what I nominate him for a good citizen
or no is his record at Florida was was
terribly flawed I felt and I know her
been moderately well through working
with Tebow and and I've seen a different
side of him but yeah the issue isn't his
Urban Meyer a bad guy the Urban Meyer
used blind loyalty to his mentor Earl
Bruce and looking past deficiencies and
character and major character flaws and
Zack Smith and I believe he did and I
believe he looked past it to a point
where it it was bordered on being
fireable but without knowing all the
facts and right now I mean Zack Smith
has denied everything I mean not that he
has symbol to be believed I watched his
interview on ESPN as I'm sure you guys
did and I mean he was he was as
cringe-worthy an individual as I have
seen in a situation like that so it's
hard to take him seriously in anything
he says because he is he is out to
defend Earth admire at all cost which is
time Urban Meyer apparently has been
defending and covering for him for a
very long time all good stuff I
appreciate your time know you're busy
and we'll talk to you during the season
thank you always a pleasure Dan Caesar
that's Paul Finebaum ESPN radio host for
more Dan Patrick show to the audience
channel 239 on DirecTV or download the
Dan Patrick show ass
you
[Music]